es war heute der tag der entscheidungen
darüber was für lockerungen ist in den
chor ohne regeln geben wird und
tatsächlich waren es am ende nur sehr
sehr vorsichtige lockerungen bei mir im
studio jetzt bild vize paul ronzheimer
frau wir haben vorhin die
pressekonferenz von angela merkel
gesehen was sind für dich jetzt oder
generell für alle natürlich die
wichtigsten entscheidungen die jetzt
heute getroffen worden sind jalil die
kanzlerin merkel hat es eine
zerbrechlichen zwischenerfolg genannt
das bedeutet sie sagt zum einen
deutschland ist relativ gut durch die
krise gekommen hat die pfleger das
gesundheitssystem gelobt aber hat
gleichzeitig gesagt wir können jetzt
nicht sofort um steuern sondern es
braucht weiterhin das bekannte
kontaktverbot so hat sie es ausgedrückt
also alle maßnahmen bleiben bestehen
dazu kommt dass auch angekündigt wurde
dass großveranstaltungen bis zum 31
august auf keinen fall stattfinden
werden was man auch schon so geahnt
hatte aber dennoch jetzt definitiv auch
für die planung der festivals der
konzerte und dann ein bisschen hoffnung
zumindest gemacht haben die
ministerpräsidenten und die kanzlerin
damit dass man gesagt hat
läden mit bis zu 800 quadratmeter fläche
könnten wieder öffnen auch da ist es
noch nicht so ganz klar wie das
austariert ist was die schulen angeht da
sollen abiturienten jetzt erst mal
zurückkehren aber auch weitere klassen
berufsschüler und weitere und die die
die grundschulklassen auch am ende und
friseure
ab anfang mai ebenfalls aber es ist
nicht die große öffnung die sich
möglicherweise nrw-ministerpräsident
armin laschet erhofft hatte sondern es
ist sehr sehr zurückhaltend und auch
dort es wird wahrscheinlich das werden
wir morgen erfahren eine art
flickenteppich geben insofern als dass
bayern wieder einen sonderweg wählen
wird und möglicherweise auch kleinere
geschäfte noch nicht aufmachen will
im übrigen werden ich glaube ich ist
mein gefühl zumindest auch in der
nächsten woche wird es daher heftige
debatten geben zum beispiel um die frage
wieso ist eigentlich sein kann dass
kirchen weiterhin nicht öffnen dürfen
und wie es sein kann dass zum beispiel
leben weil bis zu 800
rath meter öffnen dürfen also kleinere
läden aber größere leben nicht dann
stellt sich natürlich die frage moment
mal bei kleineren leben bin ich doch
viel näher an bestimmten personen und
könnte möglicherweise den virus weiter
geben das virus weiter geben und in
größeren kann ich mich viel freier
bewegen dazu kommen die
unterschiedlichen maßnahmen der
bundesländer also das gibt viel viel
diskussion spot enzian und ich glaube so
meine analyse dass das heute nicht
besonders glücklich kommuniziert worden
ist vielen dank dir paul für diese
einschätzung ja es sind weiterhin viele
offene fragen manche wurden noch gar
nicht beantwortet manche sind seit heute
erst da und deswegen wollen wir jetzt
noch einmal uns anschauen was genau
heute verkündet worden ist in dieser
zusammenfassung was sich jetzt also
ändert was die deutschen wissen müssen
kontakt beschränkungen bleiben vorerst
dritter meist dort das datum bis dahin
keine frage weiterhin kontakt verboten
es gibt keine masten pflicht nur die
empfehlung das heißt niemand wir dazu
gezwungen eine maske zu tragen
außerdem haben gar über die schulen
gesprochen schrittweise ab dem 4
mai werden schulen wieder eröffnet dann
erstmal die abschlussklassen und dann
nach und nach einen richtigen fahrplan
firma hat es gerade gesagt gibt es dazu
noch nicht
außerdem kleine läden dürfen dann unter
auflagen wieder öffnen
dort war ein großer streitpunkt was
kleine läden bedeutet also welche
quadratmeter zeit tatsächlich geht und
was in dieser hinsicht sinnvoll ist
friseure hingegen ab dem vierten mai
dürfen sie wieder öffnen und es gab
keine einigung über gottesdienste dieses
thema das in deutschland auch heiß
diskutiert wird wird weiterhin
besprochen noch dürfen keine
gottesdienste in deutschland abgehalten
werden dass also die wichtigsten fakten